bonjour mr massa est capital en merci
d'être avec nous sur rt france alors
pourquoi elle lançait cette action de
groupe contre l'état français
bonjour non cette action de groupe parce
que ça fait des années qu'on lutte côté
problématique
il ya eu pas mal de productions
scientifiques sociologiques des rapports
on a eu aussi le premier procès où
l'état français a été condamné en 2016
pour faute lourde
on a eu plusieurs avis recommandations
du conseil des droits de l'homme du cnc
dh et qui demandait à l'état français de
seyssel profilage ethnique et vu que ça
ne fonctionne pas on n'a toujours pas de
mesures concrètes prises par le
gouvernement et que récemment le
président de la république a lui-même
reconnu que une frange de la population
était contrôlé à cause de leur apparence
et que c'est insoutenable
donc nous déposons et plusieurs ong
cette action pour 1 go inciter les uns
apprennent illusion nécessaire et la
période est particulière puisque ces
derniers mois des affaires mêlant
violences policières accusations de
racisme également se sont succédé elle
le racisme et il a mal profond d'une
partie de la police française selon vous
nous déplorons de dénoncer les
discriminations systémique
il s'agit pas de s'enfermer dans des
comportements individuels de policiers
il s'agit vraiment de dénoncer le
système puisque ce qui amène un certain
nombre de policiers à contrôler une
partie de la population c'est la
politique du chiffre mis en place c'est
le fait que les sanctions ne sont pas
pris quand il ya des rives et des
comportements inappropriés de certains
policiers
donc ce que nous dénonçons nous c'est
les discrimination systémique
donc nous demandant à ce que la loi par
exemple l'article 78-2 du code de
procédure pénale français qui encadre
les contrôles d'identité
on demande à ce que se soit améliorée
que ce sera plus clair et que ce soit
pas un chèque en gris pour certains
policiers ce qui ne nie pas l'existence
même de policiers insistent au sein au
sein des commissariats mais notre propos
à nous non
action à nous c'est sur les
discrimination systémique ce pour
répondre aux critiques depuis lundi la
ministre de l'intérieur gérald darmanin
a ouvert le beauvau de la sécurité est
ce que vous espérez quelque chose de
cette concertation
écoutez le bobo c'est une réaction du
gouvernement par rapport aux propos
tenus par le président de la république
reconnaissant justement les contrôles au
faciès donc là nous attendons de voir
pour l'instant nous n'y sommes pas
invités donc nous attendons de voir ce
que ça va donner le bouvau mais on peu
cruel que ce soit je dirais un peu
impacté entre le ministre et les
syndicats de police et la question des
relations police population n'est
franchement pas un sujet prioritaire
dolbeau tel qu'il est présenté le
contrôle au faciès est ce qu'elle sait
c'est un mal français finalement qu'en
est il de nos voisins européens
bah écoute et où dans d'autres pays il
ya ce genre de problématique c sauf que
les mesures sont déjà prises
mais en france le contrôle au faciès
gers est un véritable poison puisque sa
mine le sentiment d'appartenance de la
république de 2 de la part d'un certain
nombre de citoyens
on a le sentiment d'être des citoyens
d'origine contrôlée on a ça nous renvoie
un sentiment de déclassement également
donc aujourd'hui la problématique et
puis c'est surtout que l'état français
prenne ses responsabilités ils seront en
capacité de protéger l'ensemble de ses
citoyens et qui met en place qu'on
appelle l'égalité de traitement
dernière question rapidement le syndicat
alternatif police a qualifié votre
action de groupe comme une manoeuvre
politique de la part d'organisations
anti fait qu'est-ce que vous répondez à
sa wii nommé les syndicats et chez
peut-être klein d'une des difficultés
c'est que les syndicats de police
ici en france s'enferme dans une espèce
de postures corporatistes et qui
refusent de se rendre compte je dire le
monde n'est pas parfait
les humains ne sont pas parfaits les
systèmes ne sont pas parfaites non plus
qu'il ya des problématiques au sein de
la police et dans l'est dans la relation
dépôt des policiers avec les citoyens
que les syndicats veulent ignorer
malgré les décisions judiciaires qui
démontrent le contraire je vais pas
rentrer ne savait pas avec les syndicats
puisqu'il s'enfermer dans une posture et
qui par ailleurs je dirais met en danger
les propres policiers je pense que vous
avez pratiquement plus de 55 policiers
qui se sont suicidés sur l'année
dernière on peut demander aux syndicats
qu'est ce qu'ils font pour protéger
justement ces fonctionnaires et aux
comment ils s'y prennent
merci beaucoup mais remet à sa capitale
en d'avoir répondu à nos questions je
rappelle que vous êtes le président de
la mc ds la maison communautaire pour un
développement solidaire